Day 2 at CES here we are at the Venetian
Expo and one thing that you guys will
see here is there are a ton of ebikes I
actually rode a few of them and the cool
thing is they are not only uh high
quality the quality has gone up a lot
but they're very unique interesting
designs instead of just copies of each
other I'm over here at the hyperbike
booth and you have a lot of different
options here terms of ebikes lots of
designs including this really awesome
old school kind of retro design but the
thing that really stood out to me are
these kids ebikes right here and that's
important to me because I have two kids
one's almost four one's almost two so
right here you have this more kind of
like a bicycle Style with these
footrests which is really cool very low
seat which is nice over here you have
this blue kind of dirt bike style which
is great for off-roading and that's big
for us because we actually Camp a lot in
the summer basically the whole summer so
it's going to be awesome for the kids
but check this Chopper out this is an
absolutely beautiful design I love the
red paint and the cool thing about this
is that it's a chopper style so this
seat is very low to the ground very easy
to reach the ground so cool for smaller
kids you can just right around the
street this is awesome definitely a
really cool booth and lots of ebikes
this year let's take it over to Max
yeah and starting from the kids now
going up the ebikes are getting crazier
because this one right here has full-on
turn signals got a massive light and
there's a license plate on there so if
you actually want to make this thing
legal and be riding on the streets you
can do so and the quality is going up
with everything the suspension the
displays the lights the shocks they're
all hydraulic ebikes are getting really
really nice now there's a ton of
different 3D printing and printing
technology and we have something very
unique here which is a tattoo printer so
right there I just got the maxtech
tattoo now don't worry it's not going to
last that long about one week so if you
have regrets well it's going to go away
next up we have some of the most unique
and best designed Chargers out there
from our sponsor charge this is the
charge 170 because it puts out 170 WS
maximum through a combination of three
ports at the top and the coolest part is
that it puts out 140 WTS through one
port which means it can fast charge a
16-in Macbook Pro I love the design that
you can see it's transparent has a
built-in display that shows the charging
level how much wattage is going through
it and believe it or not this is
actually the one that we chose to bring
on this trip to charge all of our tech
devices next up we have the ice mag Max
saave charger that has 10,000 Mah hours
of the battery with a builtin cooling
fan and then finally they have their
newest product which is their flow mini
power bank has this cool transparent
design and it actually has
interchangeable ports so you can see it
has a USBC Port plugged in but you could
swap it out for a lightning if that's
the device that you have all you do is
you simply plug it into your iPhone and
now it's charging it's taking up minimal
space and on top of that it also has
this Loop where you can pop it out and
there you go you have another cable to
fast charge a second device these are
some of the coolest Chargers that I've
seen so thanks charge for sponsoring
this video so I'm at birdfly right here
and this is super cool there's a couple
incredible things the first thing I want
to show you guys is their original bird
feeder with a camera so not only can
feed the birds but you can actually
enjoy watching them now it gets even
better this is their new model you can
put two different kind of seats you can
watch the birds and the crazy thing is
it can actually uh identify over 6,000
Birds over 150 hummingbirds so it's a
really cool experience and they're using
a lot of Technology we can actually put
different clips together it'll give you
a notification with a bird that's there
what kind it is so you can actually go
outside and watch it and this is my
favorite this is their new birdhouse now
as you see you can buy the set comes
with the camera outside but on the
inside you actually have another camera
with a nice antenna so if a bird goes in
it's going to make a nest you can watch
uh the eggs you can watch them hatch the
birds grow create a video for you
shorten it to together and at the top we
have a solar panel so you can put this
anywhere and you'll get that connection
you can actually see your back door if
you place it there um and if you're home
you can go outside watch the birds so if
you're interested in that it's something
that's very unique and it really takes a
bird feeding and bird house game to
another level all right guys so we've
been walking a lot here at CES yesterday
was 13,000 steps now it's like 7,000
we're just dead tired and there's a lot
of massage chairs here so I might as
well take advantage and the technology
in these is absolutely insane look at
that it's Lifting me up getting me into
a comfortable position these are
probably insanely expensive we've seen
multiples of these on different levels
and halls but ah time to relax next up
we have a little company called segue
you probably recognize that from a long
time ago making those little scooters
that you stand on but they are
innovating this right here is a hybrid
side by side that they announced today
and it's going to production next year
the build quality on this you just go
around take a look at the engine the
suspension everything hybrid this is
sick I didn't know segu is doing this
kind of stuff but check out what else
they're doing they're doing these ebikes
right here they have kind of like a
regular casual style bicycle but then
they have this which looks like a retro
cyber dirt bike kind of thing with this
awesome X light this thing right here
will go 60 Mi on One battery you could
actually stack two of them together and
when you go Offroad instead of being
limited to 20 mph you could go probably
around 40 m an hour Offroad on this
thing and you can see that it has pedals
built in but you can actually lock these
if you'd like to just go with the
throttle by itself so they have this
going on and then over here they have a
bunch of their scooters which are
extremely high quality they have a
couple of new ones here they have their
ST1 right here and it actually has fine
my support So if you lose it or somebody
steals it you could actually track it
down and find where it's at same thing
with those bikes that I showed you back
there they also have fine my support
with LTE built in which is just crazy
they also have their little S2 their
little mini that goes 11.2 mph with 21 M
range that'll save your legs probably
especially at CES they also have these
things the GT1 and the
GT2 which go crazy crazy fast so CES was
cool we saw a lot of different Tech and
we met a lot of our fans it was nice to
see you guys we got to take a bunch of
different pictures and we also saw a lot
of brands that we wanted to work with
and collaborated before like we got to
see mof that was a really awesome
experience as well so that part of it
was awesome and of course we have
another day of CES tomorrow is going to
be a lot more chill we're going to have
a lot more fun so make sure you guys
don't miss out on part three of our
video series we have a cool little extra
bonus there make sure you guys click
that button above to subscribe check out
the other videos right over there and we
will see you in the
next
[Music]